interestingly as well you know his son
saying the Republican Party have
disappeared people are saying free
Donald Trump there are t-shirts already
this is a story that will go on and on
and on and whatever side you're on this
is a story that will Captivate shock and
interest the world thank you so much
indeed for watching Jeremy Carr live
tonight we're starting by for Rosanna
Lockwood will take you through the night
keep it talk we will bring you the
latest news over to you Rosanna
[Music]
thank you so much Jeremy Kyle they're
handing over what a 90 minutes of
analysis that was what is going down in
Manhattan today the lower court
Manhattan with Donald Trump they're the
45th American president of course
standing in front of a criminal court
facing charges currently under arrests
on 34 charges against him as well we
have these pictures from court and the
question is have the Democrats won today
this is a politically motivated witch
hunter indeed have they won in the short
term just by getting these photographs
out there or is it a bad long-term play
we'll be discussing that plenty more but
if there's one thing that could be said
about this it is Donald Trump once again
making lemonade out of lemons I'm going
to be joined here in the studio and
currently joined the studio by author
and historian Tessa Dunlop and my times
radio host Adam Bolton just the people I
went alongside me on a day like this
because we're going to be talking a lot
about historical contexts both both of
you let's just start by getting your
reaction to what we've seen so far play
out in the last hour I mean Adam I know
you're a keen historian uh yourself but
obviously uh Tess you're an accredited
historian uh what do you think this
means within the sort of great panopoly
of modern U.S history and the presence
you've covered in your career well it is
the first time that we've seen a
president indicted so that's a first but
then Donald Trump was also the first
president to be impeached twice so the
Donald Trump show continues my own
feeling however is that this doesn't
take him any nearer to the White House
it will help him raise money for his
campaign in the short run but he's going
to have a lot of legal problems going
ahead which may even deny him the
Republican nomination but uh what is
absolutely clear is the majority of
Americans don't want him back as
president and even within the Electoral
College he looks doomed on that front
and that may be why his own party had
decide to ditch him in the course of
campaign yeah next year your view hasn't
been swayed At All by the amount of
campaign donations they managed to raise
over the weekend well by his standards
it's not that much I mean he's got eight
million and you know one of the sort of
dirt little secrets of uh Donald Trump
is that campaigning has always been a
way for him to raise money so he's
continued to do that but he hasn't built
up uh the level of support which he had
before the rate of donations and indeed
if you look at the demonstrations in New
York today which he called for uh I mean
they're pretty pathetic that
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green with
her bullhorn was pretty much drowned out
and taken away you mean you weren't
convinced when she yelled out he was
Nelson Mandela and then Jesus you
weren't swayed by her oratory it doesn't
matter about me the crowd wasn't
particularly impressed either they all
carried on waving their balance and
pushing their own particular level you
know that we didn't see January the 6th
today did we no we didn't but I think
Trump
would buy the giant kind of personality
but actually the polarization of
American politics what this has done to
either side has led to really the sort
of democratic rot the lack of faith in
all their key institutions which has
propped up that country and led it to be
the greatest country on the planet in
the 20th century yeah but on the other
hand people are saying look he's
politically motivated the district
attorney that he said that he was going
to prosecute Donald Trump all true but
in America you elect your district
attorney anyway and therefore he has
Adam when people stop believing in the
system when they don't know what's true
or not when there's misinformation
spread around like Donald Trump for that
and yeah how do you get rid of that you
get rid of the man maybe but not the
problem can you not argue that's what I
was going to say on Adam's point that it
is Donald Trump that has led the
precedent for picking away at the fabric
of democratic institutions in the U.S
and one could argue that what does the
US stand for if not for its democracy
its justice system its courts and if we
take the line of questioning that we
hear a lot we've been hearing a lot over
the last 90 minutes actually on this
network this idea of sham trials
kangaroo courts you know you hear it
again and again does that mean that the
US justice system just doesn't work I
don't think it doesn't work and actually
what you're going to see here like a
sort of giant monster slowly masticating
it will run its course and nobody knows
actually what's going to happen and what
the implications are for the primaries
or or the 2024 presidential elections
the American justice system is much more
negotiable and provisional than the
system in this country or in France you
know you've got individual states with
different laws you've got federal crimes
at massive level and you know just
remember how did they bring our Capone
to Justice they didn't do him for being
a gangster they did him on tax evasion I
mean that's that's how America Adam why
this why this matters is today at the
same time and not making the headlines
and the way Donald Trump is we just saw
Finland enter NATO we've just got 800
more miles of border with Russia
actually what happens in America has
direct implications for the geopolitics
of the world and at the moment our
freest democracy are strong longest
military power on the planet is severely
compromised well hang on we might be
better off talking about that I agree
with you it's more important than the
fate of Donald Trump but they bleed into
each other However the fact that NATO
has expanded along the Russian border is
a massive V sign to Donald Trump who
tried to hollow out NATO and as we know
uh thought that President Putin was a
Jewish and don't forget he could come
back in as a president in 24. and it
will affect us of course if Donald Trump
and that's why we're talking about it
here on talk to you know you might be
watching us from your sitting room in
Manchester this evening thinking not
more Trump for God's sake there's else
going on in the United Kingdom but he is
the leader once was the leader of what's
called The Free World if he does again
of course the implications Ripple around
the world as Tessa and Adam just laid
out I want to talk a little bit about
the historical context of this as well
because uh Donald Trump first U.S
president to face criminal charges as we
pointed out impeached twice before but
this criminal charge thing there he is
in court this afternoon slumped over at
the desk they're looking like any other
ordinary citizen pretty much in the dock
if we can call it that behind the table
um but he's not that's the first time
he's not the first uh world leader
that's ever faced criminal charges of
course uh Francis Nicholas Sarkozy was
done on corruption South Korea's Park
also done on corruption as well and of
course
he's been bouncing in and out of the
Courts for decades different Fates
awaited all of those people different
penalties political suspension Etc but I
think what is key here what stands out
for Trump is can he bounce back from
arrest even though he's not wearing
handcuffs but from this picture we're
seeing this afternoon in the courthouse
straight back to the White House Boris
Johnson who's he's not in the courts at
the moment but he is being pursued by
the privileged Committee of the House of
Commons which could end his political
career so we're not we're not exactly
exempt from this not immune no
when he was first teached he was
impeached twice of course that was about
a then unknown Ukrainian president who
he was trying to arm twist into doing
dirty work against Biden in order for
him to get a multi-million pound deal to
shore him up on the donbass he that
wasn't convicted and that means that he
can still stand for high office you know
I look back and I think if only on that
case the Moment of Truth for Donald
Trump I was there in Washington DC it
was the second impeachment trial in the
Senate where the Senate was clearly
wobbling on whether to impeach him or
not and in the end uh the Republican
Party decided that in their own
interests of re-election fundraising
they would let him off after January the
6th that was the moment and since then
Trump has carried on with his show he
could have been finished off then if he
had been convicted by the Senate that
would have disqualified him from running
from Office extraordinary his power
isn't it it really is and I think that's
important context as well and what he
does with this as well because whatever
happens Trump obviously takes control of
that narrative we've seen it happen
today let's bring in a view from
Stateside joining me as lawyer Alan
dershowitz who has written the book get
Trump the threat to civil liberties due
process now constitutional rule of law
Alan so great to speak to you just give
us your sense of what we're seeing today
is it politically motivated Witch Hunt
oh there's no question it's politically
motivated I don't think there's a single
honest person who could pass a lie
detector test and say that a district
attorney in Manhattan would indict
anybody about Donald Trump on these
flimsy flimsy charges we haven't seen
the indictment they may have a picture
of him a videotape of him shooting
somebody on Fifth Avenue but that seems
doubtful it seems likely that this case
surrounds payment of hush money never in
history has anybody paid hush money and
then disclosed it on a public corporate
form so this is a made-up case the man
ran for district attorney as a Democrat
on the promise to get Trump he decided
not to go after him that he got
tremendous political pressure people in
his office quit uh editorials were
written against him his re-election was
in danger and so he decided to get Trump
so we looked through all the statute
books to try to find something he
couldn't find it so we made up a
misdemeanor state to a federal you don't
know they met him on something economic
but it's it's it's a political trial of
course Alan I understand the arguments
for it being a political trial I
understand the way Brig was voted in and
that it's in Manhattan and New York and
the rest of it but saying that it's a
made-up offense or a made-up trial
doesn't isn't that enormous allegation
in itself
if it's about the what I said is I
haven't seen the indictment but if it's
about failure to make a public
disclosure in a corporate form about a
hush money payment that you've made it's
made up if it's based on a federal uh
campaign contribution law which the
federal governments refused to prosecute
it's made up look if they get him for
undervaluating the uh 40 Broadway or
overvaluating it that's a different
matter maybe they'll have something
there but they'd have to realize they'd
have to go after virtually every major
real estate operator in New York I have
no doubt even before seeing the
indictment unless there's a major
surprise that no one else but Donald
Trump would have been indicted and the
best proof of this is that the
predecessor in the DA's office didn't
indict him offensive and he
said he didn't think he should be
indicted nothing's changed there's no
new evidence as far as we know there's
no new law what's changed other than the
political pressure so I think the
concept of a made-up crime is an
accurate one again I have an open mind
if there is new evidence of a dramatic
violation of law I'd favor I'd favor
prosecution I'd favor prosecution of
anybody who has committed a crime that
other people are regularly prosecuted
for no one is above the law but no one
is below them yeah I mean uh arguably
it's not the strongest misdemeanor in
Trump's War cabinet I'd agree with you
there there is actually a porn star out
there Stormy Daniels who says this did
happen of course we'll wait for the
details of the 34 uh counts uh as you
said but there was some sort of
misbehavior here of course it's been
plenty there's been plenty more in
Trump's presidency but do you do you not
think that the American public just
deserve better isn't it better just as
just to see someone serve just Justice
sure and that's why I vote against them
twice and I'll vote against them a third
time I don't like his conduct I don't
like his misbehavior uh he did wrong
things paying hush money in my view is
wrong those are not crimes
his attorney already served a prison
term for paying hush money so if it was
wrong for him it could be wrong for
Donald Trump couldn't it oh please don't
say that his attorney served a prison
term for pleading guilty to what the
prosecutor has told him to plead guilty
to let's let me tell you how it works
I've been doing this for 60 years they
got Michael Cohen on previous matters
relating to cheating on taxes he could
have gone to jail for 20 years and they
said to him we'll make a deal
you plead guilty to a co-conspiracy with
Donald Trump and then we'll let you off
on a relatively minor charge so that's
why it's inadmissible in court that
Cohen pleaded guilty to a conspiracy
with Donald Trump
appointees is you're saying there's no
there's no possible crime here I'm
saying there was a crime in that case
and that could transfer I just
because we do have a picture of
side Court this breaking so let's take a
look the latest image of course all
images there we go raising his fist in
fact that sounds like Trump Tower uh
I've just been told this was just
outside court but that's outside Trump
Tower that was on his way to court
earlier on uh today we'll bring you more
pictures as we get them throughout the
uh throughout the next hour because we
do expect Mr Trump to be leaving Court
very soon do standby we're going to be
having plenty more conversation about
all this throughout the next hour it's
going to be a very fluid flexible
breaking hour we've got tests we've got
Adam in the studio we thank Alan
dershowitz for his contribution just now
next tonight historic day that's for
certain but Donald Trump really the
victim of politically motivated Witch
Hunt as he claims will continue debating
it next
[Music]
thank you we're leading Britain's
conversation oh no uh with the people's
Channel no what are you every little
helps for God's sake is nothing original
anymore it's finger licking Goods I'm
loving it look let's be honest we don't
have any fancy speech writers here but
we do and I promise you discuss the
issues that matter to you yes I'm back
talk TV not with Morgan just before him
Monday to Thursday at 7pm join me just
do it well that one too
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
foreign
politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember a if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
that's me Rosanna Lockwood in for peers
he's on holiday for a few days of what
is he missing look at this Donald Trump
sitting in court in lower Manhattan
Courthouse of course business is going
to be looking at this from his son
lounger on his phone sure watching the
show right now hi Piers so is it a Witch
Hunt or is Trump facing Justice we are
going to continue this conversation
joined in the studio by Dr Tessa Dunlop
and Mr Adam Bolton and down the line
here by Joe Borelli the co-chair of
Donald Trump's New York campaign let's
start with you Joe you've had a big
Insight obviously into the workings of
the Trump campaign no surprises there
but talk to us a little bit about what's
happening today I'm sure you've got some
strong views but I'm particularly
interested in the way that the Trump
campaign is working with the narrative
here
well it's not even working with the
narrative it is fundamentally The
Narrative of who Alvin Bragg is I mean
this is someone who ran for office to be
a prosecutor by telling voters he's not
going to prosecute as a matter of fact
his pitch to the voters was to prosecute
as few felonies as possible and to
minimize most crimes to misdemeanors or
outright dismiss them he's made good on
those promises by the way we've seen
record numbers of dismissals both for
misdemeanors and felonies so he's doing
that the only person he promised to
prosecute on the campaign Trail was
Donald Trump that is unique in American
District Attorneys That's Unique in
American prosecution of crimes that is
not something that's the norm and it
should really a chill a lot of people to
the core that there are prosecutors who
would act like that and now that we're
seeing the details this is a crime that
most prosecutors including Bragg himself
around the country have declined to
prosecute this is not something that
would even normally rise to the level of
a crime no I'm going to ask you the same
thing I also had Adam dershowitz uh Alan
dershowitz rather about five minutes ago
which is this is this not you know a
prosecutor making something up making up
a crime making up a misdemeanor
shamtrial these are the words that we
keep hearing surely not in the United
States of America in 2023 is that really
what you're alleging
well I mean think about what is the
heart of the issue right this is someone
who paid a settlement to a woman uh to
save his family from embarrassment uh
that is something which is identical to
what Bill Clinton has done uh that is
something identical to what a lot of
people do Under the advice of their
Council while they're settling some sort
of legal disagreement so again this was
done uh with a court case a civil case
in mind under the advice of counsel
that's why it's so bizarre uh that now
they're finding reasons to charge uh the
war president with a crime but the
prosecution clearly think that they have
enough evidence to go forward
they think they have enough evidence
because they they pool the jury a grand
jury first and now potentially a civil a
criminal jury in New York County which
is Manhattan which uh some areas of
Manhattan one percent of people voted
for Donald Trump uh if you're part of
the jury that convicts Donald Trump you
probably wouldn't pay for for a drink at
any bar in Manhattan given how
Progressive and how liberal it is that's
why you hear rumors of Trump trying to
change the venue for this trial to
another County where I live in Staten
Island for example or or perhaps
somewhere else where at least maybe half
the people might have voted for him
that's just how the system works though
isn't it that's how the justice system
works grand jury they're members of the
public he maybe he got unlucky in the
district here do you think it would have
made that much of a difference if he got
it moved to Staten Island as he'd hoped
well he still can so they couldn't move
the grand jury proceeding that happened
already uh but now they possibly can
move the trial and they probably can
make a very strong case uh that this
jury pool might be tainted uh this is
somewhere uh where Manhattan is arguably
the most Progressive most liberal place
in the United States of America uh um
not just the state of New York or the
city of New York so I think there's a
fair case uh to be to be had in that
respect
it's been trying to
um uh you know all his life to break
into Manhattan he's made his fortune
such that it is in Manhattan he lives in
Manhattan therefore he's just being
tried by his peers isn't he
well he doesn't live in Manhattan more
he moved uh when he left the White House
prior to that he was in New York and
Manhattan resident right so he's being
tried by his peers if they don't like
him it's not
is a unique scenario though uh where
most people who are put on trial
anywhere in the country uh don't have a
public opinion poll about them or or in
this case an actual election where the
majority of people have a prejudicial
view against who he might be and that
could be for or against I mean there's a
fair argument to be had in some counties
I imagine that voted that's an argument
saying you couldn't put him on trial
anywhere because everyone knows who he
is and they have an opinion it's
ludicrous yeah
but what I want to ask you Joe you look
like a youngish man and there you are
basically lampooning the judicial system
upon which your country is structured
and built and I wonder how you go
forward from this eventually Trump will
be history whatever happens and how do
you rebuild credibility in the American
system to give not only you Faith but to
be the beacon across the rest of the
world as you once were
I mean to give you a bit of background I
mean the criminal justice system under
Alvin Bragg has long been the subject of
criticism uh and if there's an
embarrassment in the process even before
this Trump indictment uh we even saw
smoke from this particular incident it's
been Alvin Breg again he's the only
person
the problem is just one district
attorney that's what you're saying so
when the future
we're talking about the Trump case and
in this case we're talking about the one
prosecutor in all of America right we
have Progressive prosecutors even in the
city
only one prosecutor has ever on day one
of his job put out a memo to his staff
saying that we're no longer going to
prosecute most felonies and misdemeanors
we are going to seek to downgrade all
crimes if you know of another prosecutor
who has put a memo on writing to his
staff saying that that I challenge you
to name them well I I would I would put
it to you that prosecutors quite often
State their priorities and they quite
often uh change uh when you have a
change of who the district attorney is
and so in that sense it's not unusual
Joe
bring in another voice on this I just
want to ask you a little bit about what
we might expect in the coming days given
that you've been so closely associated
with the Trump campaign we do expect
Donald Trump to deliver some more
remarks at Mar-A-Lago when he learns
back there later this evening just give
us a sense of how you think he's going
to play it from here
I I think there won't be too many
surprises I think we've already uh saw
some of the signaling coming from his
legal team uh that they think this is an
unfair prosecution uh but by the way
there are Federal Election Commission uh
you know violations given to members of
Congress all over New York City in the
past few years there's state election
law violations that have been given to
politicians across New York City over
the years not one has ever been
investigated by Alvin Bragg so just to
go back to that earlier point but I
think we'll hear a lot more uh from the
president himself uh talking about how
this is a witch front uh how he was
targeted before this person was even
elected to office and how no one has
been charged with a crime for doing
similar Behavior Joe have you donated to
his campaign Trail were you one of the
25 new donors apparently 25 of those
donations that pulled in this weekend
were from newbies were you one of them
no I I haven't even endorsed him yet for
2024 I mean let's be friends I was a
co-chair of the 2020 and 2016 campaign
so I am not someone coming here as a
paid represent or any way a donor of
Donald Trump in this election cycle
Let's uh thank Joe Borelli uh for giving
us your inside track on this and bring
in that investigative journalist and
author David K Johnson uh David I don't
know if you were listening to that
conversation there I know you've got a
slightly different view on things today
just tell us what this means for America
well I think this actually is a Revival
of the American promise of equal justice
for all Donald Trump's a private citizen
he's not the president of the United
States he's a private citizen uh the
district attorney has brought 34 charges
as I predicted it would be a fabric of
charges not a single thread
and I just heard Mr borrelli say no one
else but Donald Trump would charge this
really uh excuse me Michael Cohen went
to prison for this people get charged
with these crimes now if he doesn't like
the legislature's writing of the
criminal statutes he should be lobbying
to replace those legislators this is
when you strip away the political
nonsense that's being raised this is the
ordinary prosecution of someone who is
accused of violating a host of federal
criminal laws and people should
understand that Donald Trump has been
getting away with stuff for years I've
got live pictures of Donald Trump
leaving the Lower Manhattan Courthouse
these are the latest pictures not live
latest pictures of Mr Trump leaving the
Lower Manhattan Courthouse there
obviously surrounded by quite a few
members of security and the rest of it
we'll keep bringing these live pictures
as and when we get them and we're
expecting you know we haven't seen many
protests today in the sort of the
likeness of capital or six riots for
example we saw quite a lot of hubbub and
Calamity around uh Marjorie Taylor
Green's protest earlier but around the
courthouse they've managed to keep quite
a tight ring of security as you can see
here we didn't see much of trump
actually heading into the courthouse as
we showed you the picture earlier we saw
him leaving Trump Tower this afternoon I
think everyone's just checking here to
see you know does he look guilty does he
look sad does he look angry does he look
defined is he wearing handcuffs you
could just make out the sofas blonde
hair there as you make his way into the
car there'll be plenty of analysis on
this on these pictures on these types of
video as well we will be heading to a
break we want to thank David K Johnson
for joining us they'll be back with our
in-studio guests off the Rope plenty
more analysis and debate on this
thank you
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one too
myself
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back here's Morgan uncensored
peers away for a few days to present a
Lockwood in the studio for you and we
have more on this historic day trough
leading not guilty to 34 counts of
falsifying business records relating to
hush money payments allegedly paid to
Stormy Daniels now we're showing you the
pictures here the latest pictures this
is the motorcade nice aerial shop there
for you US News Bots love this type of
thing you're seeing Trump leaving the
Lower Manhattan Courthouse here with the
security in this car to keep heading
back to his own plane Trump fourth one
he's going to be flying down to
Mar-A-Lago this evening where he's
expected to make remarks in front of uh
it's probably fair to say his supporters
stand there in mongolo Mar-A-Lago in
Florida as well so we are going to
continue the debate here in the studio
these are live pictures we're now
showing you this is the motorcade the
Trump motor to go big is we're quite
freely through Manhattan they're making
its way will they take the bridge we'll
get take the tunnel who knows they're
probably just heading to an airstrip
heading to a helicopter they're going to
head off down South tomorrow Largo this
is the uh 45th American president of
course he's been he's been in court
today facing some 34 charges again we've
been uh quite Keen to point out detail
on these charges has been somewhat scant
leading up to today a lot of people have
been jumping to conclusions in a lot of
different directions we have had some
sources giving us details on what they
expect of course as well this contains
but of course we've been hearing it
described as a politically motivated
Witch Hunt that is is it the Democrats
winning today seeing Trump in court
being tried like any other ordinary
citizen or are they shooting themselves
in the long term we've had some
fascinating voices on the show already
talking to us about this somebody who
was with Trump's campaign Joe Borelli
we've heard from investigative
journalist as well who said this is
certainly not a Witch Hunt and there
really are some broader questions here
about what this means for America's
justice system uh the district attorney
in this Alvin brag we're expecting him
to speak very shortly as we show you
these live pictures of Donald Trump and
his motorcade heading down the highway
there in Manhattan there hasn't been
that much uh sort of ruckus today uh
much disruption I'm going to bring in
the panel we've got here in the studio
on this as well uh joined by Dr Tessa
Dunlop Adam Bolton and Esther kraku also
joining us looking at resplendon in
yellow thanks to three of you let's just
talk about the media circus then Tessa I
know you got some views on this and what
it really means when we consider how how
we consume this type of news it is
extraordinary I feel sort of unclean
because I know so much now about Donald
Trump I even know he applies his own
makeup which explains a lot by the way
and that a man carries a hairspray
canister Who Walks Behind him it's like
you you point a camera at something and
We Gather we watch we talk we speculate
we build do we build back Trump bigger
as a result to what extent are we
actually I say we were obviously in
Britain but the whole world is playing
this game it's massive distraction and
we know who the winners are by the way
the non-democratic countries that we've
really got a crisis with so I do think
we have to do a bit of self-examination
about the way in which we prioritize
stories like this Esther I'll come to
you because we haven't heard from you
yet on this show have you been glued to
the TV today have you been watched this
do you care do you think Brits do you
care I have I have not been glued to the
TV mainly because I'm sad I don't think
this is a very positive development for
America I don't think America is going
to be a better country because now we've
made you know I suppose targeting your
political opponents fair game
um in this way and politicizing the the
judicial system to do that
um so that's mainly been why I've been
avoiding it I also think this is a
particularly weak case I mean there are
actually two stronger cases against
Trump which I think probably have more
teeth this is clearly the weakest one um
the former D.A didn't even want to take
this up so it's clear that the current
Manhattan Dia is just doing this you
know to make a name for himself which is
fair enough you know anyone attached to
anything that brings down Trump will
always be a celebrity I feel like this
is many people's wet dream though it
comes to life you know seeing Trump the
potential of him being in handcuffs and
his mug shot and all of that but I think
we have to understand kind of the
broader implications and is America
better for this I don't think so now
you're probably going to see you know
allegations Biden and any other
political opponent and we are sitting
here as Tessa pointed out giving it air
time for yet another hour Adam from your
point of view is a journalist that's
done this kind of thing for many many
years too much air time well we are
already asking allegations being made
against Biden and and Hunter Biden his
son and you're right that ever since
possibly the impeachment of Bill Clinton
the American justice has got
increasingly politicized but
to a certain extent that's how they do
things and I would say that possibly
what we're seeing today is quite healthy
because it is at least saying Donald
Trump former president isn't above the
law now maybe this case is not found
against him but as you know there are
other cases in Georgia over asking for
11 000 votes well there's evidence of
that and and and you know this just may
be the way things work in America it is
very political judges are elected but
you've got the stop gaps of juries of of
the grand jury and then if there's a
criminal child a jury there it it's
rough is that really a stock up though
because for someone as politically
incendiary as Donald Trump everyone has
an opinion on him you know that's just
saying you don't believe in the jury
service
an argument to actually move it outside
of Manhattan to maybe start an island
just because because clearly I mean this
to us this to a certain extent is what
the electors of the district attorney
want to see they want to see an attempt
to bring someone who they regard as a
crook and we just heard from David K
Johnson widespread allegations they want
to test that and bring it bring it bring
to justice that he's got a perfectly
Fair legal system but in a way Adam the
problem is the sort of Q and on leaders
and the oath swearers and those who
rushed up against the capital people
genuinely believe in the disinformation
that the systems against them against
their man and I want to know that
there's a corruption
people to sue each other over banging
into each other on the ski slopes
this is taking it to A Whole New Year
polarization and the system ultimately
uh will work come on in your lifetime
you've never
but I think our next guest from the US
is really going to give us something uh
more to consider this is Mark Burns
here's Trump's spiritual advisor Mark I
believe you are joining us to run down
the line if Florida you're very close
eight to Mr Trump I know this are you
expecting to be there at Mar-A-Lago by
his side this evening when he delivers
those remarks
absolutely heading there right now as we
speak um again this is most definitely a
Witch Hunt I mean this is unprecedented
has never happened in the history of the
United States of America this is not a a
prosecution of Donald J Trump this is
clearly a persecution for uh election
interference at the highest category and
so the DA's office should be extremely
ashamed of themselves for uh
politicizing this and really uh you know
tying up the hands of the justice system
in America Americans are fed up uh they
see themselves in Donald J Trump that's
why his polls are shooting up even
higher that's why he raised over seven
million dollars in 24 hours because the
American people aren't fooled by this
Witch Hunt by the D.A look I I think
some Americans see themselves in Donald
Trump but clearly some some do not and I
just want to pick up one of our guests
Esther's point about this being a sad
day a sad day for the U.S and you may
think of it in a different way but
internationally when we look at this we
do wonder some of us do wonder is it a
sad day for America to see a former
president in this position but also to
see the the justice system being picked
apart and criticized like this
well absolutely this is an extremely sad
day
um for the American history this is a
stain a black eye on the history of the
United States of America and again I
mean again is that uh um um I'm
President Grant who was arrested for
speeding in his horse buggy right uh
those charges were later dropped uh this
has never happened in the history of the
United States of America I mean listen
the U.S and the D.A in Manhattan has
clearly uh have a vendetta against
Donald J Trump uh the media has found
Donald J Trump guilty back in 2015 the
moment he came down the golden escalator
and announced his candidacy for
president of the United States of
America it was that day he became guilty
of some charge at the Manhattan D.A
campaign on the on the on the on the
goal to ultimately find Donald J Trump
guilty of something this is as far as
this is literally has poured gasoline on
an already Empire and American people
are even more outraged and supportive of
Donald Trump Mark I don't think you
could argue though that we haven't uh
news channels around the world debate as
pundits around the world haven't given
it some debate some argument from both
sides of the aisle as as a man of Faith
uh can you understand the other side of
this argument
well I mean clearly you know the Bible
says very clear that he the son set free
is free indeed we're talking about if
we're looking at this from a spiritual
point of view we're talking about an
action a sin that happened years and
years ago in which I know Donald Trump
has repented
Thou shalt not commit adulterate Thou
shalt not bear false witness doesn't it
that's completely
he'll think the same God that healed you
my friend
to avoid conviction until this point we
all need you praying on our side
let's wrap off on these Smiles Amen to
some Smiles today let's say that Mark
Burns thanks very much we wish you all
the best this evening down there in
Mar-A-Lago we're going to continue this
debate so much more in this historical
day in America coming up next with our
panelists in the studio Esther Adam uh
and Tessa as well and there we go we're
gonna close out with these live shots as
we head into the break of Donald Trump's
motorcade heading towards his leg
thank you
foreign
[Music]
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one too
thank you
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to Piers Morgan I've said
it's Rosanna Lockwood in for Pierce the
next few days bringing you back with
these live pictures from Manhattan
Trump's motorcade they're heading
towards Trump Force One he's gonna fly
back to Mar-A-Lago after having faced
these charges being arraigned in court
in Manhattan's lower District this
afternoon whenever you need these live
pictures from inside the District
Attorney's office or The Press Room
indeed for Alvin Bragg the Democrat
elected D.A who has been so much talked
about in the lead up to today of course
given the charges that he has bought
against Trump given that he has somewhat
some would argue campaigned on getting
Trump and now he's got them we were
expecting these comments from Alvin
Bragg in the last 15 minutes they
haven't arrived yet so we might get them
in the next 15 minutes if you're lucky
before we hand over to the talk as ever
it's a very fluid and moving situation
here in the studio nothing has gone as
we thought it would but it's been so
much fun and so interesting to hear all
the different different sides of the
debate we hope you've enjoyed it so far
we're now going to continue that we're
joined by talk TV contributor Paula and
Adrian political journalist Ava Santina
and former special advisor to Boris
Johnson Alex Crowley thank you both so
much former BBC journalist Laura
trevelyn also joining us too down the
line I believe you're in New York Laura
and I know that we were going to bring
you on to talk about um slavery
reparations we also have said on Twitter
it's what we're going to talk about this
show we will have to talk about that
another time but obviously some of our
viewers might recognize your name from
this story at the moment however you're
a big former BBC journalist you are in
New York give us your sense of what's
happened today and what's it been like
being there
well Rosanna is pretty extraordinary not
since 1872 when President Grant was
arrested by police for speeding in his
horse-drawn buggy has an American
president had a brush with the law in
this way and I tell you that the scene
in La Manhattan which is just a couple
of miles away from where I'm talking to
you has been absolutely extraordinary so
much security road closures around the
court as you would expect a real circus
atmosphere and this of course is
President Trump's Hometown this is where
he grew up New York City it's where he
became famous it's where he's known was
known as The Playboy the man who was
about town clubbing and this is not as
you know a city where he's politically
in favor at all it's a city that he has
a love-hate relationship with and it's
the city where he appears this morning
this afternoon and just this
extraordinary scene but I think what I
would say is that these are the least of
his troubles when it comes to the law uh
far more serious if he's indicted will
be the federal investigation into his
role in attempting to allegedly overturn
the 2020 election and also that separate
investigation in Georgia president Trump
on tape saying find me the 11 700 votes
that I need to win this state from Joe
Biden those are the much more serious
charges I think but this is very New
York very taudry there he is accused of
falsifying business records over hush
payments to a porn star and it was a
city that made Donald Trump as well
before we head to the panel and students
want to ask you Laura as a a real sort
of journalist voice as well most of your
career at the BBC a broadcaster do you
think it's right that we're giving us so
much air time in the UK
absolutely I mean this is hugely
significant and probably just the
beginning of a process this is
accountability this is the rule of law
this is a former president being brought
to account now many people in America
have doubts about these charges this is
consensual sex essentially with Stormy
Daniels but he is accused of being
involved in a hush money payment during
the 2016-16 campaigns so she wouldn't
talk about it in the closing days of the
campaign so yes it's very significant
what if she had talked about the affair
would it have made a difference I mean
probably not but yes it's enormously
significant this is a man who if he were
elected president again would he
withdraw America from NATO would he be
supporting Ukraine and its war against
Russia in the way that Joe Biden is no
certainly not Donald Trump is someone
who wanted to shake up the world order
so yes it's hugely significant that you
should be talking in Britain about the
fact that here he is facing the rule of
law Laura trevelyn speaking to us live
from Neil thanks so much Laura for
bringing us the view from the ground
we're going to return back to our studio
panelists now and as we're showing you
again these live pictures from New York
you've got helicopters circling you've
got all sorts watching Donald Trump
tracking his every move as he makes his
way back to Marlo it's such a shame that
we can't bring you his live remarks from
Mario Lago but don't you worry plenty of
dissection across them across the shows
tomorrow let's come back to the studio
now though turn to Paula turn to Ava
turn to Alex off pack here on the Piers
Morgan show great to see you all and
we've got a legal mind we've got
political Minds as well let's start with
the legal by Paula
um we've been speaking I don't know if
you saw our previous guest talk about
you know the US Constitution what this
means about picking apart U.S democracy
and the justice system what's your view
isn't this so important though for for
it to happen bearing in mind the Capitol
Hill riots and the loss of lives and and
not only the deaths but also the impact
that it had on the people the families
the community is it's got to happen
we've got to see this and can I just say
what I do not understand as a British
person looking across the water
why are you paying him 47 for a t-shirt
why
I've got something coming in my ear
puller and producers telling me that
Trump has not been issued with a gagging
order when it comes to this okay
obviously we know he likes to talk and
we'll come maybe back to Alex on this
the communication side of things but uh
to what extent do you think that changes
things and how this court case is going
to be dragged out well I don't think it
changes things at all I think it's a
very sensible thing if you would have
gagged him then all you would have done
is feed the frenzy of conspiracy that
his followers so need to survive if you
allow him to talk I suspect he will
probably talk himself into a situation
that he can't talk himself out of Alex
would you agree with that is Anna and
how would you if you were in Trump's
campaign team sorry to put you in that
position but how would you be dealing
with this look Trump will be loving this
this is perfect for Trump what does he
want he wants attention he wants the
world's media looking at him speculating
on his every single move the worst thing
that could happen to Donald Trump from a
political perspective is nobody talking
about him so this is great and yes the
charges are serious and some of the
charges potentially to follow a series
but from a purely political campaign
perspective this is great because his
great strength is drowning out the
airwaves so that none of his other
opponents can get a word in this is
fantastic for him and what what the
establishment in America who oppose him
needs to just try and understand is that
if they want to beat him they need to
take the attention away from him not put
more on him uh in terms of how he might
drag this out though could you see an
argument for that from a sort of
political campaigns and Communications
point of view to really keep even if it
means he is literally campaigning from a
prison cell if that's what it takes I
think he would love that I think that I
think he would consider that to be a
campaign advantage to be able to say
that we've seen the T-shirt we've seen
the T-shirt power and the t-shirts out
and I'm sure his campaign team are
thinking actually we'd love a picture of
him in a Cell because that would that
that would that would get his supporters
even more rather Ava yeah I mean I
couldn't agree more looking like a
martyr is so helpful to his campaign I
mean he's steaming ahead now in the
polls which is just almost farcical it's
quite laughable and there was actually a
fascinating little tidbit in Rolling
Stone yesterday they reported that he
actually had the option to appear via
Zoom link and he came in person because
he loves the spectacle but you know if
you were in the Democrats at the moment
I think that Joe Biden is actually
taking the wrong approach he's actually
been out today touring a factory which
is almost hilarious because no one is
watching that no one is looking but he
has done the right thing by not talking
about Trump and not giving him any
Oxygen because that's exactly what his
supporters are craving if you were if
you were in charge of the democratic
campaigns team
what would you be suggesting that they
do in order to change the direction
which this is going because it feels
like Donald Trump and his team have
rested control of the narrative I would
look to ASA Hutchinson who launched his
bids for the Republican nomination and
it was completely drowned out no one
looked at it because everyone was
looking at Trump heading to court or
preparing to go to court and I would say
do nothing be silent and don't engage
don't feed don't give him oxygen now
there's someone in all of this that
hasn't actually been mentioned much
whilst we've been talking about the US
Constitution everything else and that is
Stormy Daniels who's the woman at the
center of it and she's been somewhat
vocal on Twitter the last few weeks and
then sometimes she's sort of quite it's
a and that is really what is at the
center of this I know some say it's not
the most lethal of the misdemeanors in
Trump's War chest when could have gotten
on so much more but just from a behavior
point of view from a lack of Statesman
point of view do you think this is being
lost Paula um I am glad and I'm going to
refer to her as Stephanie because that's
who she is the whole fact that we're
talking about her as stormy is again
this kind of message that he wants to
get across about this woman who is a
mother who is a wife
um who is somebody who was put in a
position where she had little choice so
Stephanie as far as I'm concerned is
brave she is courageous and I am glad
and I think quite ironic bearing in mind
how religious he is and a lot of his
followers are that it is Mary Magdalene
who potentially could have the last say
in this
Let's uh let's talk to them Alex about
that because I think that's a really
strong point you made Paula about
um about the woman at the center of this
but we were hearing from some of our
guests on the show earlier that you know
if you look at other Democrats you see
there's been cover-ups let's talk about
Bill Clinton let's talk about you know
what happened with Monica Lewinsky as
well it it almost feels like in order to
be president of the United States
there's got to be stuff in the locker
well I think to most American voters
they will think that the situation of a
president or a presidential candidate uh
paying hush money to a woman who they
feel might embarrass them for obvious
reasons is a fairly normal State of
Affairs but there is a kind of double
standard here isn't there in America
when it's Bill Clinton Bill Clinton's
still a saint he's still the Democratic
kind of God that sits there that can do
no wrong but when it's Donald Trump that
does exactly the same thing or more or
less a comparable thing he's he's the
guy in the gutter they've got
they've got to work this out Ava do you
think it's a tool similar to British
politics yes extraordinary parallels I
mean Trump's stormy or Stephanie I
suppose says Boris Johnson's Jennifer
arcuri look I want to thank you all
Paula Ava Alex in the studio all of the
guests all the panelists who've had the
last time it's great to have you with us
Rosanna Lockwood info Pierce Morgan
London census that is it for me what up
whatever you do tonight make sure it's
uncensored good night
foreign
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel don't
worry every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what that one too
thank you
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it Joe